c'était un des symboles de
l'émancipation féminine une origine qui
remonte au début des années soixante à
londres la minijupe sa paternité
on la doit à une femme la britannique
mary quantz en 1967
cette styliste londonienne prédisait un
bel avenir à sa création
je crois que la baby gym deviendra un
jour un classique dès son apparition en
angleterre
la minijupe devient synonyme de liberté
féminine dans la rue les femmes
affichent leurs jambes un moyen de
s'affranchir des codes vestimentaires de
l'époque
à l'image des grandes robes des jupes
longues je pense que les anglais sont de
très belles jambes et que c'est plus
facile pour elle de porter ces modes
très vite la minijupe s'exporte en
france elle se démocratise grâce au
couturier andré courrèges en 1965 des
personnalités la dot com brigitte bardot
ou france gall l'humoriste sophie
daumier se moque des réactions qu'elles
provoquent
jusqu'à quelle hauteur la minijupe
laisse pas indifférent indifférentes les
jeunes filles leçon face aux remarques
dans la rue elles font face aux regards
réprobateurs et assume
vous êtes un mini jeu de martin par
exemple est ce que vous aimez les beaux
jours oui j'aime c'est une loi les
plaintes et j'habite alain chabat
la minijupe s'attire les foudres d'une
partie de la société qui crient au
scandale notamment les hommes à l'image
des journalistes pierre dumayet léon
zitrone et pierre sabbagh
voici leurs réactions 1966 après avoir
vu ces images sur la ligier
j'entends bien moi j'aime pas la mode
diminue pourquoi j'aime pas tellement
quelque chose mais pourquoi ne
faites-vous pas descendre la minijupe la
minijupe a bouleversé les moeurs de
l'époque
à tel point qu'elle alimenter encore les
discussions douze ans après son
apparition en france en 1977 andré
courrèges revenait sur son lancement
c'est une démarche assez réactionnaire
contre une couture ou une façon de
s'habiller assez bourgeoise est aussi
une aide à une évolution morphologique
une évolution aussi sociale
la minijupe reste un élément majeur de
l'émancipation féminine depuis 2015 elle
a même droit à sa journée mondiale tous
les six jeux
[Musique]